miami has three real horses in their
starting rotation one of them
is on the mount today pablo lopez you'll
see a lot of changes from pablo lopez
he's got
seven starts this year where he's giving
up two runs
or less and against the mets here in
miami he is 2-0 with a 1.86
era jonathan vr will lead things off
pablo's first of the day
is lined up to center field sierra right
there hardly has to move
a step at a half maybe to his right he's
got it one pitch one out
good start for pablo and francisco
lindor
coming up as lendore goes against the
shift and gets a base hit
one out single for lindor cameron maybe
coming up low ball four
so will the door single and a walk to
maven the former marlin who had been
over for nine will bring up dom smith
with two on and one out
smith the fly ball center field for
magneris
sierra he's out in front of a change up
that time and sierra makes the catch
runner bluffs at second
so two men away now runners at first and
second and here
is nito tomas nito's on well maybe
because nito's made like johnny bench
the last five games
soft chopper anderson's gonna let it
roll it's a fair ball at least it is now
now it stops
tomas well when you're hot you're hot in
field hit base is loaded
pablo lopez not a fan of that and that
loads the bases with two out for
wilfredo tovar
swing and a miss pablo came back and he
strikes out tovar good change up there
his first punch out in the ball game
gets him out of this first inning and
the mets leave him loaded
joey lucasie is going to try to provide
what the starting pitching has really
provided this year
their fifth in baseball with a 2.95
era but the met starters the last six
games
are averaging less than four innings
pitched per start
and casey they'll need 15 outs today
jazz chisholm left-hander
in the lead off there's the breaking
ball the churn from joey lacassey
he strikes out jazz chisholm on three
pitches so an impressive start
for a guard the mets need a lot from
today miguel rojas coming up
easy for lindor he retires his
counterpart miguel rojas
aguilar with two outs nobody on he gets
jesus aguilar to swing and miss on the
fastball away
and a good first inning for joey le
casey strikes out too
so one out nobody on for khalil lee
pablo a 20-pitch first
inning about a couple of hits in a walk
and there's a swing and a miss
by lee so he's got his second strikeout
and now two outs nobody on for the
pitcher luke casey and on two two a
swing and a miss
pablo blew him away so two punch outs
and a one two three second that's the
inning that
pablo needed we'll head to the last of
the second now adam duvall to start the
second against joey lucasie no score
deval swings and misses on a pitch in
the dirt for strike three
casey's retired four straight three with
strikeouts an encouraging start for
lucasy
another swing and a miss brian anderson
is punched down
joey lucasie feeling good today five up
five down four by a strikeout swinging a
miss strike three
joey lucasi strikes out the side he's
fanned
five of the first six that he's faced
today
after challenging first hitting pablo
lopez an easy one two three
second he's out there for the third now
there's no score the one two to lindor
and it's taken for strike three over the
inside corner a good looking change up
from pablo lopez that's the fourth
strikeout for lopez
the o2 to maven a swinging a miss pablo
struck him out with a change up
so we're seeing more of that change
today than we did against the dodgers
last time out
and just used to pick up his 5th k of
the game already 2-2 to smith
is in the air to left field going back
out of duvall way back onto the track
and he made the catch what a play in
front of the bullpen on the run
toward the wall somehow he pulls it down
to end the inning
five strikeouts thus far for joey lucasi
in six outs
wallach strikes out and another k for
lucasi
and six out of the first seven that he
has faced five in a row
magneris sierra as the first marlins hit
today
well there goes the no hit bin here
comes pablo lopez
probably looking to put him over casey's
got to play at second
over to first double play
1-6-3 la casey to lindor to dominic
smith
and lucasy's face the minimum through
three joey lucasi
has faced the minimum nine hitters
through three innings he has six
strikeouts
this is the best we've seen joey lucas
no question about that miguel rojas
takes strike three
called he didn't like it but joey lucas
is loving it
seventh strikeout and a season high
three and two thirds innings for the
casey
swing and a miss joey le casey is on
fire
that's why they call him joey fuego
billy casey had his
best outing as amid today one of the
best outings he's had in his big league
career
taken out after only four innings and 43
pitches
it gives way now to immense bullpen that
was used a lot last night although sean
reid foley is certainly a guy the mets
can get
multiple innings out of they are going
to walk sierra and there he goes down to
first base
faces loaded two outs in the scoreless
game sean reid foley trying to escape
against the pitcher lopez
strike three right down the middle reed
foley
walked right to the edge but he keeps
the marlins off the board the base is
left loaded in the fifth
lopez not really an innings eater he's
only gotten through seven once in his
career
swinging a miss a fastball up strikeout
number eight
for lopez chops one toward anderson at
third
anderson so reliable on to first and
it's another
one two three inning for pablo lopez so
he's through
seven for the second time this season
the mets are going to bring aaron loop
in to face pinch hitter corey dickerson
with anderson at third cooper at first
one out corey dickerson though
is five for nine in his career against
luke
and dickerson it's a fly ball into
shallow left field maven coming on he's
gonna make the catch
runner tags he's coming home anderson
the throw to the plate and andy
is safe at the plate the ball got away
they had him
and the home plate um by alfonso marquez
was about to call him out nito dropped
the ball
a sac fly and a one-nothing marlins lead
richard bleyer on defeats dominic smith
you've got the tying man pros at second
the potential go ahead man francisco
lindor at first with two outs for the
mess
and it's taken for ball three
wow wow bleyer was six steps to the
dugout
i was halfway to a commercial break oh
that's a strike what a break for the
minutes
now smith for the base hit to right on
his way to the plate
he'll score the tying run dominic smith
comes through
after richard blyer didn't get the cold
strike three
i don't know why it always seems to
happen that way but when a a call is
missed that way
castro tired the first two and with two
men away that'll bring up miguel rojas
dominic smith with a dive all the way
from the seat of his pants
to throw out rojas a magical move by
dominic smith to win the inning
aguilar of course struggling he has just
won for his last 27
000 for three today but he does have
power
it's this ball in the air toward right
center vargas reaches out
dives and he hung on janice vargas
hangs on on a diving catch to rob
aguilar
just have to love the enthusiasm of this
mitz team
and the marlins have the winning man on
with two outs of the night for garrett
cooper
who had the big swing late last night
he's got a big swing in the ninth
tonight
payoff pitch coming this will fly ball
out to deep left center field gary
cooper
is the hero today
[Applause]
boy did they need this win